From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Why aren't you more mad?
你为什么不更生气一点？
I think I'm just too tired to be mad. It's like, when I think of it, I get exhausted. I get a little desperate. I feel like a little bit like-- I feel a little bit, like, underwater.
我想我只是太累了，没法生气。怎么说呢，每当想到这件事，我就筋疲力尽。我感到有点绝望。我觉得自己有点——有点像是在水下。
This is my coworker, Sean Cole, who's a producer here on the radio show. And the thing that brought him to this state is a bed-- a bed he does not have. He ordered it back in September when he moved to a new apartment.
这位是我的同事肖恩·科尔，他是本广播节目的制作人。让他陷入这种状态的是一张床——一张他还没有得到的床。他在九月份搬进新公寓时就订购了这张床。
And this is where I've been sleeping since I moved in-- on the floor, on my old mattress, awaiting my new bed.
自从搬进来，我一直睡在这里——睡在地板上，躺在旧床垫上，等待着我的新床。
Just to be clear, the mattress for the new bed arrived right away after he ordered it. It's rolled up like a burrito near the window. The issue is the bed frame and the headboard. They're still AWOL, undelivered, absent, four months after ordering. And I'm talking to Sean about this because today's program is about all kinds of different sorts of runarounds, and he is in the middle of a sort of classic one, one lots of us have experienced.
需要说明的是，新床的床垫在他下单后很快就到了。它像个墨西哥卷饼一样卷在窗边。问题在于床架和床头板。下单四个月后，它们仍然下落不明、尚未发货、不知所踪。我和肖恩聊这件事，是因为今天的节目是关于各种各样的“跑断腿”经历的，而他正处于一种我们很多人都经历过的典型困境中。
For the record, the bed that he ordered is a queen-sized bed from the Casper online store. As a podcast producer, he told me he felt like a living cliche ordering a product that is advertised on so many podcasts, but he says he really liked the bed. It's got an angled, cushioned headboard to lean against when you're reading at night. Sean is somebody who's never really fixed up a place with nice furniture, and he was finally getting around to it, and he was excited. And at first, the delay was a completely excusable kind of thing. The bed was backordered, which, you know, happens with furniture.
声明一下，他订购的是Casper网店的一张大床。作为一名播客制作人，他告诉我，他觉得自己像个活生生的陈词滥调——去订购一个在无数播客中打广告的产品，但他确实很喜欢这张床。它有一个带角度的软垫床头板，晚上看书时可以靠在上面。肖恩以前从没真正用漂亮的家具布置过住所，他终于打算这么做了，而且很兴奋。起初，延迟发货完全是可以原谅的。床缺货了，你知道的，家具行业常有这种事。
It was supposed to be ready for delivery on November 18. But the 18th of November comes, 18th of November goes, it does not show up. Sean reaches out to Casper.
它原定于11月18日发货。但11月18日到了，又过去了，它还是没出现。肖恩联系了Casper。
They said, you'll hear from our delivery partner. OK, get a text from the delivery partner. It was a company I had never heard of, called RXO. RXO texts me and says, hi, we have scheduled your delivery for September 26. And I'm like, it hasn't been September 26 for, like, two months.
他们说，你会收到我们配送合作伙伴的消息。好的，我收到了配送合作伙伴发来的短信。那是一家我从未听说过的公司，叫RXO。RXO给我发短信说：“嗨，我们已将您的配送时间安排在9月26日。”而我想说，那都已经不是9月26日快两个月了。
Sean calls RXO and reschedules the delivery, this time for a date that's in the future, not the past. But this is the first of what will be many texts and communications from RXO that make no sense at all.
肖恩打电话给RXO重新安排了配送时间，这次定在一个未来的日期，而不是过去。但这只是RXO随后发来的许多毫无意义的短信和沟通中的第一条。
The new delivery date is in three weeks. That day finally arrives.
新的配送日期在三周后。那一天终于到了。
I get up, strip the mattress, pull it off of the floor, set it up so it'll make it easier for them to take away.
我起床，拆掉床垫，把它从地板上拉开，摆好，方便他们搬走。
So it's leaning against which wall?
那它是靠在哪面墙上的？
It was leaning against the wall in the office, against my books. I wait for them to come.
它靠在办公室的墙上，靠着我的书。我等着他们来。
Around 10:00, he gets a text telling him his bed will not be delivered. He needs to reschedule. He calls to find out why.
大约10点钟，他收到一条短信，通知他床不会被送到了。他需要重新安排时间。他打电话去询问原因。
And they said, oh, yeah. No, we can't bring it to you because you asked for the haul away service to take away your old mattress.
他们说：“哦，是的。不，我们不能给你送货，因为你要求进行旧床垫回收服务。”
But couldn't this truck still drop off your thing, even if they weren't going to haul away the old mattress?
但即使他们不回收旧床垫，卡车难道不能把你的东西放下吗？
Right. Yeah. Good question. Like, why does not being able to take something away prevent you from bringing me something?
对。是的，问得好。为什么无法把某样东西运走就会阻碍他们给我送来某样东西呢？
The delivery is rescheduled for Monday, a few days later. Monday comes. They text, saying it's going to be Tuesday. No explanation why. An hour and a half after that, they text again, saying that now it won't be delivered Tuesday.
配送被重新安排在几天后的周一。周一到了。他们发短信说要推迟到周二。没有解释原因。一个半小时后，他们又发来短信，说周二也送不了了。
And so I call them, and I'm like, what's the deal? And they go, oh, there's been a truck breakdown. And I was like, oh. So when can it come now? And they go, oh, hang on a second. And they look at their notes or whatever. And they go, oh, no, no, wait. You are good for tomorrow.
于是我打电话给他们，问到底是怎么回事。他们说：“哦，卡车坏了。”我说：“哦。那现在什么时候能送？”他们说：“哦，请稍等一下。”他们查看了记录什么的，然后说：“哦，不，不对，等一下。你明天就能收到了。”
And I was like, I am good for tomorrow? They were like, yeah, because it's already been added to the route. And I'm like, isn't there a truck breakdown? Like, what-- you know, like, was that just something you said? Like-- and I still don't know the answer to that.
我说：“我明天能收到？”他们说：“是的，因为它已经被加到路线里了。”我说：“刚才不是说卡车坏了吗？那是你们随口胡说的吗？”我到现在都不知道答案。
I have to say, this is one of the most annoying things about this kind of runaround. At every stage, you get answers that leave you sort of squinting and scratching your head, trying to understand them. Every explanation is a non-explanation.
我必须得说，这是这种“跑断腿”经历中最令人恼火的事情之一。在每一个环节，你得到的回答都让你眯着眼挠头，试图去理解它们。每一个解释都不是真正的解释。
So then, Tuesday, I get up again. I strip the bed. I pick the mattress up off the floor. I lean it up against the wall. And then I get a text saying, your delivery is confirmed for Thursday.
然后，周二我又起床了。我拆掉床，把床垫从地板上抬起来，靠在墙上。接着我收到一条短信说，你的配送确认在周四。
This time when he calls, there's no explanation at all, just an apology. Thursday comes.
这次他打电话时，对方没有任何解释，只是道歉。周四到了。
And on Thursday, I get up. I do not strip the bed, nor do I pull the mattress off the floor, because beginning to learn.
周四那天我起床，既没拆床，也没把床垫从地板上拉下来，因为我开始学乖了。
Of course, it doesn't come.
当然，它没来。
And I call them, and I'm like, what's going on? Then they go, oh, there's a hard hold on this order. And I'm like, why is there a hard hold? And they go, oh, there was a duplicate on the order docket, two bed frames and headboards here that are scheduled for shipment for the same person.
我打电话给他们，问怎么回事。他们说：“哦，这个订单被强制锁定了。”我说：“为什么会被锁定？”他们说：“哦，订单上有重复项，同一个人的名下安排了两个床架和床头板发货。”
They thought it might be a mistake, and they didn't want to ship until they knew. Sean wonders why didn't they just contact him and ask if he ordered two beds. And also, has this been on his paperwork from the start?
他们觉得这可能是个错误，在弄清楚之前不想发货。肖恩纳闷为什么他们不直接联系他，问他是不是订了两张床。还有，为什么这件事从一开始就没在他的记录里显示出来？
Then that's always been the case, right? Like, why am I only finding out about this now? And that means, like, it was never going to come or something? And--
那这种情况一直都存在，对吧？为什么我到现在才发现？这意味着它根本就不会送到，或者什么的？而且——
And now you're wondering, is this even true that there's a problem in the paperwork?
现在你肯定在想，订单记录里有问题这件事到底是真是假？
Well, no, because it seemed so specific. Like, why would you make up something like that? Unless it's just like-- I don't know. I don't know. I guess the answer is, I don't know, and it's maddening.
嗯，不，因为它看起来太具体了。他们为什么要编造这种事？除非是——我不知道。我不知道。我想答案是，我不知道，这让人抓狂。
Then, after thinking they had to deliver two beds to Sean, they admitted they didn't have any. They did a week-long dock search, finally showed up with a bed, but it was the wrong size, which put Sean back at square one. Early on, Sean started to keep a record of all these interactions with RXO and Casper. And at this point, it is 18 pages long.
后来，在认为必须给肖恩送两张床之后，他们又承认一张都没有。他们进行了一周的码头搜索，终于带着一张床出现了，但尺寸不对，这又让肖恩回到了原点。早些时候，肖恩开始记录所有与RXO和Casper的互动，现在这份记录已经有18页长了。
If this document were a poem, what would it be called?
如果这份文件是一首诗，它叫什么名字？
(LAUGHING) It would be called--
（笑）它会叫——
Sean's a published poet, by the way.
顺便说一下，肖恩是一位出版过作品的诗人。
--uh, "How Do You Sleep?"
——嗯，《你怎么睡得着？》
When we reached out to RXO and Casper, the bed company, to find out how they do sleep at night, given their treatment of Sean Cole, the answer was refreshingly honest. Casper's VP of operations emailed admitting, yeah, the last few years, because global supply chains have been so crazy, Casper has experienced, quote, "a myriad of disruptions."
当我们联系到床垫公司Casper和RXO，想知道鉴于他们对肖恩·科尔的处理方式，他们晚上怎么睡得着时，得到的回答出奇地诚实。Casper的运营副总裁通过电子邮件承认，是的，过去几年里，由于全球供应链非常疯狂，Casper经历了“无数的混乱”。
He did say that only a tiny portion of the shipping is done with RXO, and they're trying to work with RXO to improve things. 90% of their customers, he said, rate their experience with RXO favorably, meaning 10% do not. Sean is 1 in 10. Pretty bad odds, if you ask me.
他确实表示，只有极小部分的运输是由RXO完成的，他们正试图与RXO合作改善现状。他说，90%的客户对RXO的体验评价是满意的，这意味着有10%不满意。肖恩就是那十分之一。如果你问我，这胜算相当小。
My take is that they never actually had a bed for him. Sean feels like he's come this far, he doesn't want to start over with a different company. A runaround hits different people different ways.
我的看法是，他们其实根本就没有货。肖恩觉得既然已经走到了这一步，他不想换一家公司重新开始。这种“跑断腿”的经历对不同的人有不同的影响。
I'm the perfect person to give the runaround to because I am preternaturally indisposed to flipping out-- you know, demanding a result.
我是一个最容易被糊弄的人，因为我天生不爱发火——你知道的，就是那种强硬要求结果的性格。
You're saying you wouldn't do these things.
你是说你不会做那些强硬的事。
I would not do these things. I'm the person who you want to give the runaround to because, like, I'm not going to, like, reach through the phone and try to strangle you. Like, even when I freak out, I'm polite about it.
我不会。我就是那种适合被“跑断腿”的人，因为我不会气急败坏地去抓着电话威胁对方。即使我抓狂，我也表现得很礼貌。
True. Sean can get a little worked up talking to me about all this, but the harshest he ever got with Casper or RXO is a sternly-worded email that sounds like it was written by an English gentleman in the year 1820. Quote, "This is beyond unacceptable. Please let me know what Casper intends to do to rectify this situation. Yours, sincerely."
确实。肖恩在和我聊起这些时可能会有点激动，但他对Casper或RXO说过最狠的话也只是一封措辞严厉的邮件，听起来像是1820年的英国绅士写的。原文是：“这简直令人无法接受。请告诉我Casper打算采取什么措施来纠正这种情况。您诚挚的。”
A runaround-- where you float in that weird information limbo where you can't tell what the truth is, where you don't get what you want, in a contest of wills with some other person or entity, and it goes on, and on, and on, it just doesn't end, it tests you. It shows you who you are.
“跑断腿”——你漂浮在那种奇怪的信息真空里，分不清真相是什么，得不到你想要的，在与某个人或实体的意志博弈中，它没完没了地持续着，就是不结束，它在考验你。它让你看清你自己。
Today on our program, some very different kinds of runarounds and some very different reactions to them from people who are being pushed to their very limits. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，将会有一些完全不同的“跑断腿”经历，以及人们在被逼到极限时所做出的不同反应。请继续收听。
Act One, "Like the Show 48 Hours, Except a Lot More Hours." So this first story is about somebody who, like Sean, is being given the runaround, but the runaround is about something much more consequential to her life than a bed frame. And the woman it's happening to, over and over, she has to decide whether to cut her losses and walk away, or stay with it and fight her way through. Reporter Brenna Smith, who first wrote about this for the news site, the Baltimore Banner, explains.
第一幕，“像48小时节目一样，只是时间长得多。”第一个故事是关于某个人，她像肖恩一样正在经历“跑断腿”的遭遇，但这件事对她的生活来说比一张床架重要得多。而这个不断遭受这种待遇的女人，必须决定是及时止损、放弃一切，还是坚持下去、抗争到底。首先为新闻网站《巴尔的摩旗帜报》报道此事的记者布伦娜·史密斯解释道。
Even before this whole thing began, Renee's life involved a lot of running around. She's busy-- got three kids, works days and nights as a home health aide. When money's tight, she also drives for DoorDash and Instacart.
即使在这一切开始之前，蕾妮的生活也充满了奔波。她很忙——有三个孩子，白天和晚上都做居家护理员。手头紧的时候，她还要去跑DoorDash和Instacart配送。
She spends a lot of time in her car, like a lot of busy people. But unlike a lot of busy people, Renee told me and my producer Chris, she usually chooses the slowest possible route to her next destination because--
她花了很多时间在车上，就像许多忙碌的人一样。但和许多忙碌的人不同，蕾妮告诉我和我的制作人克里斯，她通常会选择去下一个目的地时最慢的那条路，因为——
I'm scared of beltways. I mean, I don't do beltways. I take the long way everywhere.
我害怕环城公路。我是说，我不走环城公路。我去哪儿都绕远路。
What do you mean you're scared of beltways?
你说的害怕环城公路是什么意思？
I'm just scared of all the traffic-- like, so many different lanes with cars. I have real bad anxiety. My nerves are bad. So I think it's just, like, so many different lanes with just so many cars flying past you, so I just prefer not to. I'd rather go on side roads.
我就是害怕所有的车流——那种有很多条车道，上面全都是车。我有严重的焦虑症。我的神经很脆弱。所以我觉得，就是那种有这么多不同车道，还有这么多车从你身边飞驰而过，所以我宁愿不走。我宁愿走小路。
Is there, like, a Renee speed limit? Like, above this--
有没有所谓的“蕾妮限速”？比如，超过这个速度——
Yeah, I don't like to go any past like 45.
是的，我不喜欢开得超过45英里。
Renee's commitment to the local roads just outside of Baltimore, where she lives, will sometimes add 20, 30, even 40 minutes to her trips. So that's Renee.
蕾妮对居住地巴尔的摩附近地方道路的坚持，有时会让她多花20、30甚至40分钟的时间。所以，这就是蕾妮。
The story I want to tell you started last spring when something went wrong with Renee's SNAP benefits-- her food stamps. Her monthly money stopped appearing on her benefits card. Fixing this took five or six trips to the social services office, filling out tons of paperwork, and three months of waiting. This isn't unusual for her or anyone on benefits.
我想讲的这个故事始于去年春天，当时蕾妮的SNAP福利——也就是她的食品券出了问题。她每月收到的补助金不再出现在她的福利卡上。为了解决这个问题，她跑了五六次社会服务办公室，填了堆积如山的表格，还等待了三个月。对于她或者任何依赖福利的人来说，这并不罕见。
Finally, a kind woman at the front desk at social services looked into her case and found some glitch in the system. She fixed it for Renee, and the next morning, everything was made right. All three months of missed benefits showed up at once. She now had almost $3,000 on her card, the highest she'd ever had. Renee felt a wave of relief. But a couple of weeks later, Renee went online to check the balance on her card.
最后，社会服务处前台一位善良的女士查看了她的案子，发现系统里有个故障。她帮蕾妮修好了，第二天早上，一切都恢复正常了。所有三个月未收到的补助金一次性到账了。她的卡里现在有了近3000美元，这是她有史以来最多的一次。蕾妮感到如释重负。但几周后，蕾妮上网查询卡内余额时——
And everything was gone, except $66. That's all I can really remember. I thought it was a mistake. I thought, well, let me get off the app. And I cleared it out and tried it again, same thing.
除了66美元，其他钱都没了。我能记住的就这些。我以为是个错误。我想，好吧，让我退出应用程序，重新清理一下再试一次，结果还是一样。
She called the number on the back of the card to make sure and found out, again, $66. First, she was just confused. And then she noticed large transactions at stores she's never visited near Washington, D.C., where she never goes, because beltways. She realized someone had somehow stolen her SNAP money. The thousands of dollars she'd just gotten back on her card was gone in one afternoon. And this is where her runaround began.
她拨打了卡背后的电话进行确认，发现确实只有66美元。起初，她只是感到困惑。然后她注意到在华盛顿特区附近她从未去过的商店里有大额交易，因为她从不走环城公路。她意识到有人以某种方式偷走了她的SNAP补助金。她刚收到的那几千美元在一个下午就消失了。而她的“跑断腿”经历就是从这里开始的。
I've been reporting on social services, like SNAP in Maryland, and I've seen SNAP fraud happening a lot. Benefits theft skyrocketed from $90,000 in 2021 to over $1.5 dollars in 2022. SNAP fraud is actually up across the US.
我一直在报道马里兰州的社会服务，比如SNAP，我看到SNAP欺诈频繁发生。福利盗窃案从2021年的9万美元激增到2022年的超过150万美元。SNAP欺诈案实际上在美国各地都在增加。
The night it happened to Renee, she couldn't stop crying and couldn't sleep. This is money she used to buy food for her kids. Without it, she'd have to pick up extra jobs, get behind on rent. So the next morning, she marched into the same government building she'd been in so many times before to fix the problem in person. Maybe she'd get the nice lady again.
蕾妮遭遇这件事的那天晚上，她哭得停不下来，彻夜难眠。这是她用来给孩子们买食物的钱。没有了它，她就必须打更多的工，拖欠房租。所以第二天早上，她大步走进她为了解决问题去过无数次的那个政府大楼。也许她还能遇到那位好心的女士。
I went down to the social services, and the same lady that fixed the food stamps was like, yeah, I remember. I just fixed them for you. And all the money that, you know, was going to come on your card-- she was almost in tears. She said, I feel so bad for you, because it's so much. She said, I've never seen that much be taken at once. She said, but I can tell you now, they're not going to-- they're not going to refund anything.
我去了社会服务处，之前帮我修复食品券的那位女士说：“是的，我记得。我刚帮你修好。”而所有应该打到你卡里的钱——她当时快哭了。她说：“我真的很为你难过，因为数目太大了。”她说：“我从未见过一次性被偷走这么多钱。”她说：“但我现在能告诉你的是，他们不会——他们不会退还任何东西。”
The woman told Renee, because the stolen SNAP money is actually federal money, Maryland couldn't pay her back. It was a statewide policy.
这位女士告诉蕾妮，因为被盗的SNAP资金实际上是联邦资金，马里兰州无法补偿她。这是全州的政策。
She said, there was nothing-- she said, I really wish we could help you. And then of course, everybody in the whole-- because you know, you're sitting there with all these people. And the window, everybody can hear you talk, because you're only walking a couple of steps to the window.
她说，没有办法——她说，我真的希望我们能帮你。然后当然了，整个屋子里的人——因为你知道，你和所有这些人坐在一起。窗户那儿，每个人都能听到你说话，因为你走到窗口只需要走几步路。
And you know, you've got the whole room looking at you at one time, so I felt so stupid. I'm crying. And I don't-- I don't like crying in front of people. I try to hold my emotions back. And it was hard that day. I just couldn't hold it back.
你知道，整个房间的人一下子都在看着你，所以我感到特别愚蠢。我在哭。而且我不——我不喜欢在别人面前哭。我试图克制自己的情绪。但那天很难受。我就是克制不住。
I first met Renee on this Facebook group for parents in Maryland who use benefits like SNAP. There were lots of parents, mostly moms, writing in, saying they had had their benefits stolen. And there was Renee, posting all the time about what had happened to her and really trying to help everyone else. "Everyone, please read this," she wrote. "If we all come together and report this to the police and social services, then something may be done." There were lots of moms who had tried to get social services to refund them. No luck. They'd also filed reports with their local police. Nothing.
我是在马里兰州的一个Facebook群组里认识蕾妮的，群友都是像她一样使用SNAP福利的家长。有很多家长，主要是妈妈们，留言说她们的福利被偷了。蕾妮当时一直在发帖讲述她的遭遇，并尽力帮助其他人。“大家，请读读这个，”她写道。“如果我们团结一致，向警察和社会服务部门举报这件事，也许会有所作为。”有很多妈妈尝试过让社会服务部门退款。没戏。她们也向当地警察报了案。还是没戏。
I talked to dozens of them, and Renee was in a category of her own. She did far more than anyone else. When I got her on the phone back then, she'd been playing phone and email tag for days, bouncing between every authority figure she could find-- the Office of the Inspector General for Maryland's Social Services, the USDA in D.C., which funds SNAP, even the Maryland legislature where she called delegate after delegate, but it all got her nowhere.
我和她们中的几十个人谈过，而蕾妮是独一无二的。她做得比任何人都多。那时我打通她电话时，她已经在电话和邮件之间来回奔波了好几天，在每一个她能找到的权威人物之间打转——马里兰州社会服务监察长办公室、资助SNAP的华盛顿特区农业部，甚至马里兰州议会，她打给了一位又一位代表，但这都毫无进展。
I just spoke to Delegate Robin Grammar, I think his name is, yesterday. And he told me that, unfortunately, no matter what I do, he said they're not going to refund the money.
我昨天刚和罗宾·格莱默代表谈过，我想是这个名字。他告诉我，不幸的是，无论我做什么，他们都不会退还这笔钱。
The police weren't any help either. The cop assigned to her case, Officer Timothy Valis, would sometimes take days to answer her texts, and didn't seem to be doing anything. He was a rookie who hadn't graduated the academy yet. So Renee did something I haven't seen anyone else do. She decided to investigate her own case. She was going to find the people who took her SNAP money.
警察也没提供任何帮助。负责她案件的警察蒂莫西·瓦利斯有时需要几天时间才回复她的短信，看起来什么都没做。他还是个没从警校毕业的新手警察。所以蕾妮做了一件我从未见过其他人做过的事。她决定自己调查自己的案子。她要找到偷走她SNAP补助金的人。
One thing about Renee, she loves true crime shows, like 48 Hours. So she knew how important the first couple of days are in any investigation. She was worried time was slipping away, so she went to the facts she had.
关于蕾妮有一点，她热爱《48小时》这类真实的犯罪节目。所以她知道在任何调查中最初几天有多重要。她担心时间在流逝，所以她着手处理她掌握的事实。
The SNAP benefits app had given her the details for every fraudulent transaction, all seven of them. They included a dollar amount, a date, and the name of each store. There had been big purchases, some over $500. Renee thought that maybe those stores could rewind their security footage to the times of those transactions and maybe identify the thieves. She texts all this to Officer Valis.
SNAP福利应用程序给了她每笔欺诈交易的详细信息，一共七笔。包括金额、日期和每家商店的名字。有一些是大额消费，超过500美元。蕾妮想，也许那些商店可以回看交易时间的监控录像，或许能认出小偷。她把这一切都发短信给了瓦利斯警官。
I said, I looked at my food stamp app on my phone and wanted to let you know I found all the store numbers that these people used my food stamp card. I sent him the picture of all that. Then he said, OK, thank you. And then I said--
我说，我在手机上看了食品券应用程序，想告诉你我找到了这些人使用我食品券卡的所有商店编号。我把这些照片都发给了他。然后他说，好的，谢谢。接着我说——
She suggested the police contact the stores, but nothing happened. So--
她建议警察联系这些商店，但什么也没发生。所以——
I called the stores myself.
我亲自给这些商店打了电话。
Most of the stores wouldn't help her. They don't show surveillance footage to customers, only police. But one manager at an international market agreed to check.
大多数商店不帮她。他们只向警察展示监控录像，不给客户看。但一家国际市场的经理同意帮忙核实。
And they pulled the video of the people that did it.
他们调取了作案人员的录像。
Wow.
哇。
So she sent me one, two, three, four, five pictures, and one four-second video of them just driving away.
所以她给我发了一、二、三、四、五张照片，还有一个四秒钟的视频，视频里他们正开车离开。
And all of a sudden, Renee was looking at the faces of the people who stole from her, security footage from a Sunday in early August. It looked to be during the day. It was bright out. The photo was grainy, but she could make out a middle-aged man exiting the store. Then, in a different photo, a woman with a low bun and a blue-striped skirt with a shopping cart.
突然之间，蕾妮看到了偷她钱的人的脸，那是8月初一个周日的监控录像。看起来是在白天。天很亮。照片很模糊，但她能认出一个中年男子从商店出来。然后，在另一张照片里，一个梳着低发髻、穿着蓝色条纹裙子、推着购物车的女人。
And you see in the back of the cart, the people that stole it, they bought cases and cases of baby formula.
你在购物车后面能看到，那帮偷钱的人，他们买了一箱又一箱的婴儿配方奶粉。
Oh.
哦。
So they didn't buy groceries. These people bought cases of baby formula. It's on the picture.
所以他们没买杂货。这些人买的是几箱婴儿配方奶粉。照片上都有。
$1,200 of baby formula, which seems weird, but it makes sense if you think about it. Formula is a very efficient way to convert food stamps into cash. It's in every grocery store. It doesn't go bad quickly, like meat. It's dense, so you can pack a lot of it into your car. And in the summer of 2022, there was a shortage of it.
价值1200美元的婴儿配方奶粉，这看起来很奇怪，但如果你仔细想想就说得通了。配方奶粉是将食品券转换为现金的一种非常高效的方式。每个杂货店都有。它不像肉类那样容易变质。它很紧实，所以你可以把大量配方奶粉塞进车里。而且在2022年夏天，奶粉还很短缺。
Renee had found the suspects and the getaway car. The footage showed them driving off in a Toyota minivan. But she still had no idea how to find out their names, their identities. And even after squinting every which way at the photos of the license plate, she still couldn't make out what it was.
蕾妮找到了嫌疑人和逃跑用的车。录像显示他们开着一辆丰田小型货车离开。但她还是不知道如何查出他们的名字和身份。即使在把车牌照片眯着眼看了又看之后，她还是看不清上面写的是什么。
If you look at it from a certain way, you could see a little better. But then once you really start to-- it's confusing. It's really hard to-- so I just kind of took that and sent that to the officer.
如果你从某个角度看，能看清楚一点。但一旦你真的开始——这太令人困惑了。这真的很难——所以我只好拿着照片把它发给了警官。
When Renee texted all this to Officer Valis, he didn't say much. Just, quote, "I updated the report with the information you've given me." He also said he'd referred her case to the department's investigative and cybercrime units. Then he stopped responding, for weeks.
当蕾妮把这一切发短信给瓦利斯警官时，他没说什么。只是说：“我已经根据你提供的信息更新了报告。”他还说他把她的案子转交给了部门的调查和网络犯罪小组。然后，他几周都没有回应。
So now he's not answering any of my texts asking if he has found anything else out, nothing.
所以现在他不回复我任何询问他是否有什么进展的短信，什么都没有。
He has not responded to you since August 13.
他从8月13日以后就没回复过你。
Nothing. No answer. I'm just like-- I just feel like people don't really care because it's not someone close to them that has needed food stamps. And this is not like $100. I wouldn't even probably even call if it was something small. This is almost $3,000. And this is not from me, this is from my children-- it's taken from my kids.
什么都没有。没有回答。我只是觉得——我感觉人们根本不在乎，因为受苦的不是他们身边需要食品券的人。而且这可不是100美元。如果是小钱，我可能都不会打电话。这是近3000美元。而且这不是我的钱，这是我孩子们的——是从我孩子们那儿偷走的。
Then, in late August, Renee receives a letter from social services. It says they looked into her case and, quote, "did not find a system error or that the card was used fraudulently." There would be no refund.
后来，在8月下旬，蕾妮收到社会服务部门的一封信。信中说他们调查了她的案件，“没有发现系统错误，也没有发现该卡被用于欺诈交易。”不会退款。
Other moms on the Facebook group had gotten the same letter, and a lot of them had given up at that point. But Renee reads the fine print. She noticed that the bottom of the letter offered her the chance to appeal this finding before a judge, with evidence.
Facebook群组里的其他妈妈也收到了同样的信，她们中的很多人在那时已经放弃了。但蕾妮仔细读了小字。她注意到信的底部写着，她有机会在法官面前带着证据对这一结论提出上诉。
I think it's called, like, some kind of fair hearing or something from social services. And I've got to prove that it wasn't me, even though it's clearly these people. I have to prove that and try to fight that in, you know, court or wherever.
我想那叫某种公平听证会之类的，是社会服务部门提供的。我得证明那不是我干的，尽管很明显就是这些人。我必须证明这一点，并尝试在法庭或其他什么地方进行抗争。
So she was going to file an appeal. It was a lot of money. And some part of her just wanted to prove that this thing had actually happened to her, that she had been robbed. All she had was grainy footage from one of the stores. She wanted a stronger case. If she could get better quality security footage from another store, maybe she could identify the license plate, which could lead you to the criminals.
所以她打算提出上诉。那是一大笔钱。她心里有一部分只是想证明这件事确实发生在她身上，她确实被抢劫了。她手里唯一的证据就是其中一家商店模糊的录像。她想要一个更有力的案子。如果能从另一家商店拿到画质更好的监控录像，也许就能辨认出车牌号，这就能顺藤摸瓜找到罪犯。
She wanted to go in person. But again, these stores were near Washington D.C., a beltway, an interstate highway, and another beltway away. And her car wasn't in great shape. And so--
她想亲自去。但同样，这些商店离华盛顿特区很近，隔着一条环城公路、一条州际公路，还有另一条环城公路。她的车状况也不太好。所以——
OK, we're recording. Let's see. OK. We're going to be there at 10:36.
好了，我们在录音了。让我们看看。好的。我们会在10点36分到达。
OK.
好的。
And that's how I wound up picking up Renee at her red brick rowhouse outside Baltimore on a muggy August day to drive to D.C. We managed to find a time for this after Renee performed some serious scheduling gymnastics-- got a babysitter, moved around her hectic work schedule. I recognized her from Facebook, a white lady in her 30s with a round face and big green eyes. Renee was so competent on the phone. But today, faced with the prospect of doing in-person detective work, she's nervous again.
于是，在一个闷热的八月天，我在巴尔的摩郊外蕾妮的红砖联排屋接上她，开车去华盛顿特区。在蕾妮进行了一番复杂的行程安排后——找了保姆，调整了繁忙的工作时间表，我们总算挤出了时间。我从Facebook上认出了她，一个30多岁、有着圆脸和大绿眼睛的白人女性。蕾妮在电话里非常有能力。但今天，面对要亲自进行侦探工作的前景，她又紧张起来了。
I don't need anything, right?
我不需要带什么吧，对吗？
No, I don't think you need to take anything. I think you just need to come in and--
不，我觉得你什么都不用带。我想你只需要走进去，然后——
Just go?
就这样去吗？
Yeah, just explain who you are and why you're there. OK.
对，解释一下你是谁，为什么要来这就行。好了。
We stopped right outside D.C., a CVS. Renee had already called the store and talked to a guy named Keith, a manager. We walk in to find him.
我们在华盛顿特区外的一家CVS药店门前停下。蕾妮已经给店里打过电话，和一位叫基思的经理聊过了。我们走进去找他。
Hi. Oh, I spoke to you. Keith. You're a manager too?
嗨。哦，我和你通过话。基思。你也是经理吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, OK. I'm the one that spoke to him about the baby formula that was stolen.
哦，好的。我就是那个因为被偷的婴儿配方奶粉和他通过话的人。
Yeah-- oh.
是的——哦。
They tell Renee what everyone else did-- they're only allowed to show security footage to law enforcement. But, they add, there is a police station a couple blocks away.
他们告诉蕾妮和其他人说的一样的话——他们只被允许向执法部门展示监控录像。但是，他们补充说，离这儿几个街区外有个警察局。
So if I went there--
那如果我去那儿——
Yeah, you go in there.
对，你去那儿。
They would come right over here and--
他们会直接过来这儿，然后——
I don't know if they'll come right over here, but--
我不知道他们会不会直接过来这儿，但是——
So if they come back here-- if they do, which they probably won't, but then you'll be able to show them?
那如果他们回来这里——如果他们回来，虽然可能不会，但到时你就能给他们看了？
Yeah, all right.
对，没问题。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
Within minutes, we're standing outside the police department for the small town of Seat Pleasant, Maryland, telling Renee's story. She explains that she had had her food stamps stolen. One of the cops has a hard time understanding how this crime had gone down. Specifically, how the thieves got their own card.
几分钟后，我们站在马里兰州西特普莱森特小镇的警察局外，讲述蕾妮的故事。她解释说她的食品券被偷了。其中一名警察很难理解这起犯罪是如何发生的。特别是，小偷是如何拿到她的卡的。
Because the police in my area--
因为我所在地区的警察——
Do they copy your information?
他们复制了你的信息吗？
They're saying--
他们说——
They skim it.
他们用了盗卡器。
He had my card, even though I have my card. They had a card. Like, we have--
他拿到了我的卡，尽管卡还在我身上。他们有另一张卡。就像，我们有——
They have to have your PIN number too.
他们还得有你的个人识别码（PIN）。
Yeah. He said skimmers do that.
对。他说盗卡器就是干这个的。
Well, when you skim, they punch in the PINs.
嗯，当用盗卡器时，他们会输入密码。
A skimmer is a device that thieves put over card scanners. It looks just like a card scanner, so you can't tell. It can capture your card information, including your PIN. Most EBT cards-- the benefits cards people on assistance, like Renee, use to buy food-- they don't have the encrypted chips that most credit and debit cards do. Cards with chips are harder to skim. On top of that, EBT cards don't have fraud detection services. You know, like those text messages you get about suspicious credit card transactions. Text 1 if it was you. And if not, they'll cancel the transaction.
盗卡器是小偷放在读卡机上的装置。它看起来就像读卡机，所以你根本看不出来。它能窃取你的卡信息，包括你的PIN码。大多数电子福利转账卡（EBT卡）——就是像蕾妮这样领取救济的人用来买食物的卡——不像大多数信用卡和借记卡那样有加密芯片。有芯片的卡更难被盗取信息。最重要的是，EBT卡没有欺诈检测服务。你知道的，就是那种当你发生可疑交易时收到的短信。如果是你，回复1。如果不是，他们会取消交易。
And even with debit cards, you can usually call your bank and tell them that I was stolen from yesterday, and you could get your money back. Renee's EBT card didn't have any of that. All of this has turned SNAP recipients into easy marks, even people like Renee, who never lets her card out of her sight. We try to explain all of this to the officer, who listens to Renee's story.
即使是用借记卡，你通常也可以打电话给银行告诉他们我昨天被盗了，然后你就能把钱拿回来。蕾妮的EBT卡根本没有这些功能。所有这些都让SNAP领取者成了容易下手的目标，甚至是像蕾妮这样从不让卡离开视线的人也不例外。我们试图向这位警官解释这一切，他听着蕾妮的故事。
So we have footage from the--
所以我们有来自——的录像。
Bowers!
鲍尔斯！
The officer calls over another cop, Officer Bowers. His supervisor tells him to get the footage from CVS for us. Bowers hops into his patrol car, and we get back into my car to follow him. Then, as we're driving, we notice Bowers' car has its lights flashing.
这位警官叫来了另一位同事，鲍尔斯警官。他的主管让他帮我们去CVS取监控录像。鲍尔斯跳上警车，我们也回到车里跟着他。然后，在行驶过程中，我们注意到鲍尔斯的车闪起了警灯。
I don't know what these lights mean.
我不知道这些灯是什么意思。
He's serious about his business.
他对待这件事很认真。
Yeah. It's crazy. We have a freaking police escort to a CVS. What?
是的。太疯狂了。我们竟然有警察护送去CVS。什么情况？
I'm not playing here.
我不是在开玩笑。
Yeah.
是的。
If this don't make the news. See, we're not playing? Look, he's in front of us, directing us with his lights on.
要是这事儿上不了新闻可就怪了。看，我们没开玩笑吧？你看，他在我们前面，开着警灯引导我们。
When we get there, Bowers talks to the CVS employee, who shows him to the back room. We wait out front in the store for about 15 or 20 minutes. Then Officer Bowers and the CVS employee re-emerge.
当我们到达时，鲍尔斯和CVS的员工谈了话，员工把他带到了后室。我们在店门前等了大约15到20分钟。然后鲍尔斯警官和CVS员工重新出来了。
Oh, they're out.
哦，他们出来了。
Yeah.
是的。
Same one?
是同一个吗？
That's them, yeah.
就是他们，没错。
Bowers told us it was the same woman, the one in a low bun, in a blue-striped skirt, buying hundreds of dollars of baby formula.
鲍尔斯告诉我们，就是同一个女人，梳着低发髻，穿着蓝色条纹裙子，正在买几百美元的婴儿配方奶粉。
OK. They hit up all the stores, then.
好了。那他们就是扫荡了所有的店了。
OK. Yup. Give me one second.
好了。没错。给我一秒钟。
Are we able to get the video?
我们能拿到视频吗？
Officer Bowers shows us the security footage, which he recorded on his phone. We see the woman getting into the same silver minivan after.
鲍尔斯警官向我们展示了监控录像，他用手机录了下来。我们看到那个女人事后坐进了同一辆银色小型货车。
We do have a vehicle. It's a Toyota Sienna.
我们确实有一辆车的信息。是丰田赛那。
Yeah, mhm.
是的，嗯。
Yeah, same one from the other.
是的，跟之前的那辆一样。
Yeah. So I think this is a West Virginia tag.
没错。所以我认为这是西弗吉尼亚的车牌。
The license plate, the thing that could lead them to the criminals-- it's blurry here too. But Bowers says he'd use some fancy police tool to try to figure it out. Finally, the runaround had landed Renee somewhere. She'd found someone in a position of authority actually willing to help her.
那个可能带他们找到罪犯的车牌号，在这儿也还是模糊的。但鲍尔斯说他会用某种高级警用工具试图识别它。终于，“跑断腿”的经历让蕾妮有了点收获。她终于找到了一个有职权的、真正愿意帮她的人。
A few days later, Officer Bowers calls me. He won't let me record or conference Renee in, so I have to tell her afterward what he said.
几天后，鲍尔斯警官给我打来电话。他不让我录音，也不让我把蕾妮接入通话，所以我必须事后告诉她他说了什么。
OK. Hey, Renee.
好了。嘿，蕾妮。
Hi.
嗨。
I tell her that Bowers said he thinks he found a match for the license plate, but he couldn't hand that information over to her.
我告诉她鲍尔斯说他认为找到了车牌号的匹配对象，但他不能把那个信息给她。
His supervisor will no longer let him work on the case.
他的主管不再让他处理这个案子了。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, because Baltimore County already has an investigation and that-- it can only be done through Baltimore County now.
是的，因为巴尔的摩县已经有了调查，现在只能由巴尔的摩县来处理。
Oh, my god.
我的天哪。
And so Renee's case landed back in the hands of the cop who wasn't answering her texts or calls. Renee understood Bowers was just following his boss's orders, but still.
于是蕾妮的案子又回到了那个不接她电话和短信的警察手里。蕾妮明白鲍尔斯只是在听从老板的命令，但还是——
It feels like, even though it wasn't his fault, it's like all these other people let me down. So when we went there and they actually helped us, I was so excited. I was so excited. I was thinking, OK, well, he was going to call and we're going to have some news saying that they caught these people or something, just something. And then now he's doing the same, just like every other one did.
感觉就像，虽然不是他的错，但所有这些人还是让我失望了。所以当我们去那儿，他们真的帮了我们的时候，我太兴奋了。我当时想，好吧，他会打电话来的，我们会有些消息说他们抓到了这些人什么的，只要有点进展就行。结果现在他又跟其他人一样了。
Right.
对。
I don't know what to think anymore. I mean, I could try to call Officer Valis. But if he's not answering my texts, he's not going to answer the calls either.
我不知道该想什么了。我的意思是，我可以尝试给瓦利斯警官打电话。但如果他不回我短信，他也不会接电话的。
I have no idea.
我不知道。
Now, I can-- I can contact the guy from the OIG. He was really nice, but nobody's saying anything.
现在，我能——我可以联系监察长办公室的那个人。他真的很不错，但没人跟我说什么。
Right.
对。
Just kind of keeping me in the dark, like-- you know. I don't know. It's just weird to me. Like, this happened to me. I am not some kind of-- the suspect. I am the victim that this happened to.
就是把我蒙在鼓里，就像——你知道的。我不懂。这对我来说太奇怪了。这件事发生在我身上。我不是那种——嫌疑人。我是发生这件事的受害者。
Right.
对。
(VOICE BREAKING) I'm just tired of all. I'm tired of all of it.
（声音颤抖）我真的累了。我受够了。
I'm so sorry, Renee.
蕾妮，我很抱歉。
It's just frustrating, you know? You get in touch with all these people. They promise to keep you updated, promise to call you back, and nothing. It makes you think, like, why did I even ask for their help in the first place? So, I mean, I don't know what else to do. I've done everything I could. There's nothing else for me to do.
这真的很让人沮丧，你知道吗？你联系了这么多人。他们承诺会随时告知进展，承诺会回电，结果什么都没有。这让你想，为什么我当初还要寻求他们的帮助呢？所以我不知道还能做什么。我已经做了所有能做的事了。我再也没什么可做的了。
Yeah.
是的。
While she was trying to run down this $3,000, there was so much else going on in her life. There always is. In the last couple of months, a cracked tooth from stress, busted brakes on her minivan. She had to give away her dog. They couldn't afford it. One day, her carbon monoxide alarm randomly went off, and she had to call the fire department to sort it out.
在她努力追回这3000美元的同时，她的生活中还有很多其他事。总是这样。过去几个月里，压力导致牙齿开裂，小型货车的刹车坏了。她不得不把狗送人，因为养不起了。有一天，她家的一氧化碳报警器无缘无故响了，她不得不叫消防队来处理。
But surprisingly, the day after I broke the news to her about Bowers, she managed to get in touch with the cop who had been ghosting her for weeks. Remember Officer Valis, the Baltimore County cop who, this whole time, was supposed to be looking into her case? She'd reached him, in a very kind of private detective sort of way.
但令人惊讶的是，在我把鲍尔斯的情况告诉她的第二天，她竟然联系上了那个已经鬼影般消失了好几周的警察。还记得那个巴尔的摩县的警官瓦利斯吗？他一直以来都应该在调查她的案子。她竟然用一种非常私人侦探的方式联系上了他。
So yesterday, I kept calling Officer Valis. His phone is still going right to voicemail. I said, this is weird. Why-- if it's a cell phone from work, why would it be off all the time? And then finally, I said, you know what? Something told me, try from a different phone. So do you know, I called from my son's phone, and it rang.
昨天，我一直在给瓦利斯警官打电话。他的手机一直直接转入语音信箱。我说，这太奇怪了。为什么——如果这是办公手机，为什么总是不开机？然后最后，我说，你知道吗？有种直觉告诉我，换个手机试试。结果你猜怎么着，我用我儿子的手机拨了过去，通了。
[BRENNA GASPS]
（布伦娜倒吸一口凉气）
I said, oh, my god. I think he blocked my number.
我说，我的天哪。我觉得他把我的号码拉黑了。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And I was so furious when I got in touch with him. He's all like, hello? And I'm like, hi, Officer Valis? He's like, who is this? I said, this is Renee. I said, you're the one handling my case.
我联系上他的时候怒不可遏。他当时说：“喂？”我说：“嗨，瓦利斯警官？”他说：“你是谁？”我说：“我是蕾妮。我就是那个案子的当事人。”
I said, I'm wondering if, like, you blocked my number. And it made me sound like a creep, but I was so mad. And I'm like, I have been trying to contact you. And he-- then, once I mentioned about being blocked, he started being super nice to me. And I said that you guys should be getting this information, not me-- not me and the news reporter. We have been getting it. We went to the source to get the footage, nobody else.
我说，我想知道你是不是把我的号码给拉黑了。这听起来让我像个变态，但我当时太生气了。我说，我一直尝试联系你。然后——一旦我提到被拉黑的事，他就开始对我超级客气。我说你们应该去获取这个信息，而不是我——不是我和新闻记者。是我们一直亲自去获取。我们亲自去源头拿到了录像，没别人。
And then he started-- he was, like, you know, try to stay strong. We're trying. And he gave me a number to another-- like Crime Stoppers, or something like that. He said they will get on this more than anybody else. Like, what do you mean, they will get on this?
然后他开始——他说，你知道，要坚强。我们正在努力。他还给了我另一个号码——比如“灭罪热线”什么的。他说他们会比任何人更投入地处理这个案子。就像，你说的投入是什么意思？
You guys-- if you can't leave your area that you're patrolling, then somebody should be going there and doing this. Then he also tells me that, yeah, I'm pretty sure. I thought you could open another case in another area. I said, well, the other guy told me that his boss said something different, and he don't think-- this is what I mean about the runaround.
你们——如果你们不能离开你们巡逻的区域，那就应该有人去那里做这些事。然后他还告诉我，是的，我相当肯定。我觉得你可以去另一个区域立案。我说，好吧，上一个人告诉我他的老板说的不一样，他不觉得——这就是我说的“跑断腿”的含义。
We reached out to the Baltimore county police department. They said Officer Valis did block Renee's member, quote, "for a brief period of time." But they also said he was working on her case. And after Renee got through to Valis, he did start updating her more. He told her police found the skimmer that they think was used to steal her card number.
我们联系了巴尔的摩县警察局。他们表示瓦利斯警官确实把蕾妮的号码拉黑了，“持续了一小段时间”。但他们也说他一直在处理她的案子。在蕾妮联系上瓦利斯后，他确实开始更多地更新进展了。他告诉她警察找到了他们认为被用来窃取她卡号的盗卡器。
But then, in November, Renee lost the appeal she had filed. The judge complimented Renee's tenacity, saying she'd quote, "single-handedly and capably investigated the crime and identified suspects." But the judge also said that there's nothing in Maryland law that requires social services to repay stolen SNAP funds.
但到了11月，蕾妮败诉了。法官称赞了蕾妮的坚韧，说她“凭一己之力且非常有能力地调查了犯罪并确定了嫌疑人”。但法官也表示，马里兰州法律没有任何条款要求社会服务部门赔偿被盗的SNAP资金。
And so Renee wasn't going to get her money back. But she was still looking for some way. And an attorney who volunteered to help her with her case said, there is a way. You can appeal the appeal. Renee thought it over.
所以蕾妮还是拿不回她的钱。但她仍在寻找某种途径。一位自愿帮助她的律师说，还有办法。你可以对上诉结果进行上诉。蕾妮考虑了一下。
She's like, it's up to you. Do you want to do another appeal? And I'm like, no. I said, what's the purpose? Like, just to be let down over and over by different judges that are saying, I'm sorry. But then on the other hand, it's like, I already came this far. Why not try to have another appeal and do it again? My mind just goes back and forth. Like, should I, shouldn't I? Should I or shouldn't I?
她说，这取决于你。你想再上诉一次吗？我说，不。我说，意义何在？只是为了被不同的法官一次又一次地拒绝，听他们说“对不起”？但另一方面，我又觉得，我已经走这么远了。为什么不尝试再上诉一次呢？我的心思总是来回摆动。就像，我应该还是不应该？我应该还是不应该？
Answer-- I should. She filed a second appeal. There is actually one other way this whole thing could be fixed. Congress could do something. And, kind of amazingly, they sort of have.
答案是——我应该。她提出了第二次上诉。实际上，这件事还有另一种解决方式。国会可以做点什么。而且，相当令人吃惊的是，他们确实做了。
The huge spending bill Congress passed last month requires states to reimburse people who have had their SNAP benefits stolen. It's not going to help Renee though. It only applies to thefts since October. Hers was in August. Also, it ends in 2024, so it's a temporary fix.
国会上个月通过的巨额支出法案要求各州补偿那些SNAP福利被盗的民众。但这不会对蕾妮有帮助。它只适用于10月以后的盗窃案件。她的案子发生在8月。此外，该法案在2024年就到期了，所以这只是权宜之计。
But Renee's story did get noticed. She actually testified before the state senate. And later, her congressmen, who had been following this issue, introduced a bill that would fix things in a permanent way. It has bipartisan support and looks like it might actually go somewhere.
但蕾妮的故事确实引起了关注。她甚至在州参议院作了证。后来，一直关注这个问题的国会议员提出了一项法案，能够以永久性的方式解决这个问题。它得到了两党的支持，看起来很有希望通过。
The runaround-- it's a thing that can happen to you, but it can also be a strategy. You just stay in it until someone notices and does something.
“跑断腿”——这是一件可能发生在你身上的事，但它也可以是一种策略。你只要坚持下去，直到有人注意到并采取行动。
Brenna Smith. She's an investigative reporter with the Baltimore Banner, where a version of her story first appeared. The story was produced by Chris Benderev.
布伦娜·史密斯。她是《巴尔的摩旗帜报》的调查记者，她的故事版本首先在那里发表。该报道由克里斯·本德列夫制作。
Coming up, a nine-year-old on a runaround that his dad does not understand. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个九岁的孩子正经历着他爸爸无法理解的“跑断腿”。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，请收听芝加哥公共广播。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Runaround." Stories of all kinds of runarounds that people find themselves trapped in, test who they are. And other sorts of runarounds as well. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Strange Loop."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“跑断腿”。我们讲述了人们发现自己被困在其中并考验他们本性的各种“跑断腿”经历。当然还有其他类型的困境。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“奇怪的循环”。
So we now turn to a different kind of runaround. And the person you're going to hear about next, nobody is giving him the runaround. He's just running around, for reasons that are mysterious even to those who are closest to him. David Kestenbaum talked to him about it.
现在我们转向另一种类型的“跑断腿”。你接下来要听到的那个人，没有人给他设置障碍。他只是在不停地跑，原因即使是对他最亲近的人来说也是个谜。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆和他聊了聊。
The guy doing this running around in circles, he's nine years old. And I know him because I live with him. My son, Max, started doing this early in the pandemic.
这个围着圈跑的人才九岁。我认识他，因为我跟他住在一起。我的儿子马克斯在疫情初期就开始这么做了。
Max was one of those kids where virtual school was really impossible. All those faces and little boxes on the screen, he just could not focus or stay with it. His handwriting was crazy. He sometimes struggled to read his own name. At some point, we realized he didn't know the months of the year. He had big hills to climb. I worried.
马克斯是那种虚拟教学对他来说完全行不通的孩子。屏幕上那些小方格里的脸，他根本无法集中注意力或者跟上进度。他的笔迹乱七八糟。有时他连自己的名字都写不出来。在某个时刻，我们意识到他甚至不知道一年的月份。他面前有巨大的困难。我很担心。
One day, he hit on this idea of running loops around the block. We live on a weird lollipop of a street, so these were actual loops he was running, around and around. The neighbors told us he was sometimes the only other person they would see during the day. One time, an older man came out and gave him cookies.
有一天，他想出了绕着街区跑圈的主意。我们住的那条街形状很奇怪，所以他跑的确实是循环的圈，一圈又一圈。邻居们告诉我们，他有时是他们白天唯一能看到的其他人。有一次，一位老先生走出来还给了他饼干。
The running around seemed to settle his mind in a way I did not fully understand. Virtual school was tears and frustration, but running these loops reset him somehow. It was more than just getting exercise. I could see him talking to himself as he went by, but I had no idea what he was saying.
绕圈跑似乎以一种我无法完全理解的方式让他平静了下来。虚拟课程是泪水和挫败感，但这些跑圈让他以某种方式重置了。这不仅仅是锻炼身体。我能看到他跑过时在自言自语，但我根本不知道他在说什么。
He's been doing it for years now, sometimes several times a day. "I'm going for a run around the block. Sound of door closing, and then he'll be gone, sometimes for 20 minutes.
他现在已经坚持好几年了，有时一天跑好几次。“我要去绕街区跑一圈。”关门声，然后他就会跑掉，有时一跑就是20分钟。
He's done it first thing in the morning, right out of bed, when it's still dark. He does it in the rain-- annoyingly, never with a raincoat. I pile towels by the door. He'll change clothes, but then an hour later, go out again. He did it when it was -22 wind chill.
他大清早刚起床天还没亮就去跑。他在雨里跑——最烦人的是，从来不穿雨衣。我只好在门口堆满毛巾。他会换衣服，但一小时后又跑出去了。即使在零下22度的寒风中他也照跑不误。
I wanted to eavesdrop on one of these runs to hear what he was saying. Something going on out there was helping him. I wanted to understand his brain. So I had this idea of pinning a small microphone on him. He was not into it. "Max, want to wear this microphone when you run around the block?" Max-- "Next time!" Me-- "Max, I only want you to do this if you want to." Max-- "Not now." And so on.
我想偷听他的一次跑步，听听他在说什么。外面发生的事让他得到了帮助。我想了解他的大脑。所以我有个想法，在他身上别个小麦克风。但他对此不感兴趣。“马克斯，想在绕街区跑时带上这个麦克风吗？”马克斯——“下次吧！”我——“马克斯，我只想在你愿意的情况下让你这么做。”马克斯——“现在不行。”诸如此类。
But I know how to work a reluctant source. I got him after a run one evening. It was dark and raining. He agreed to a brief interview
但我知道怎么对付一个不情愿的受访者。有一天晚上他跑完步，天很黑又在下雨，我逮到了他。他同意接受一次简短采访。
I don't know anything about running. Don't ask me any more questions.
我对跑步一无所知。别再问我问题了。
It's not an interrogation.
这不是审问。
Yeah, it is. I'm tied to a metal chair.
是的，就是。我就像是被绑在金属椅子上一样。
Uh, you're just holding your hands behind your back as if you're tied to a metal chair.
呃，你只是把手背在身后，装作被绑在金属椅子上。
It counts.
这也算。
Do you remember the joke you told me the other day about ADHD? What does ADHD stand for?
你还记得那天你讲的那个关于多动症（ADHD）的笑话吗？ADHD代表什么？
Attention deficit-- hey, donuts!
注意力缺陷——嘿，甜甜圈！
Do you ever feel like that in your head?
你脑子里有时会那种感觉吗？
Yeah. Like, distracted while doing something.
会。比如，做事时分心。
And when you're running, does that ever happen?
那你跑步的时候会发生这种情况吗？
No. I'm focused on my running and my story, that's it.
不会。我专注于我的跑步和我的故事，就是这样。
A story. That's what's going on in his head out there, going around and around. He's telling himself a story. That's what the running unleashed.
一个故事。这就是他脑子里在想的事情，一圈又一圈地跑。他在给自己讲故事。这就是跑步所释放出来的东西。
I can remember the first story I ever had. It's pretty much just a little chicken, a little duck, and they were literally friends. And they waddled around.
我记得我第一个故事，基本就是讲一只小鸡和一只小鸭，它们真的是朋友。它们摇摇摆摆地走来走去。
The stories have changed as he's gotten older.
随着他年龄增长，故事也变了。
Did you have a story in your head just now?
你刚才脑子里有故事吗？
Yeah. There was this big, red monster. Like, imagine a human, then imagine him completely ash. Like, just ash.
有。有个巨大的红色怪物。想象一下一个人类，然后想象他完全变成了灰烬。就是灰烬。
It was interesting to hear this. It has an attention to detail that is sometimes not present in other parts of his life.
听这个很有意思。他有一种在生命的其他部分有时不存在的对细节的关注。
Then imagine a little red tinge coming off him. He's like a fire person. His hair's on fire. His eyes are red, like fire.
然后想象一点红色从他身上散发出来。他就像个火人。他的头发着火了。他的眼睛是红色的，像火一样。
He told me another one that was like pieces of the world had lodged in his head and recombined. This one violated multiple copyrights. The Avengers were in it, but then also Spaceman Spiff from "Calvin and Hobbes." And also, somehow--
他讲了另一个，就像是世界的碎片嵌入了他的大脑并重新组合在一起。这个侵犯了多重版权。复仇者联盟在里面，还有《加尔文与霍布斯》里的太空人斯皮夫。而且，不知何故——
I was pretending to be Arthur Dent, I think. Yeah, Arthur Dent.
我想我是在假装自己是亚瑟·登特。是的，亚瑟·登特。
From The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy.
来自《银河系漫游指南》。
What do you think it is about running and a story that is calming?
你觉得跑步和讲故事有什么让你平静的地方？
I don't know. I have no idea.
我不知道。我一点头绪都没有。
Are you thinking about a story, like, all day long, kind of?
你是一整天都在想故事吗？
All day. I run and wander during recess. And the thing-- and I usually-- sometimes I play with my friends, and sometimes I wander around, thinking about it. But yeah.
整天都在想。我在课间休息时又跑又转。然后——我通常——有时我会和朋友一起玩，有时我会到处走，想着故事。但是的。
Wow, it's like all day long.
哇，竟然一整天都在想。
Yup.
没错。
That's kind of amazing. I didn't know that.
这太神奇了。我都不知道。
Hm.
嗯。
Could you think of the story if you were just staying in the house?
如果你只是待在屋子里，你还能想到那个故事吗？
Yeah, I could, but it's harder. I could think of one, but it's harder.
能，但我能想到一个，不过更难。
Why do you think it's easier when you're running around the block?
为什么你觉得绕街区跑时更容易？
Uh, I don't know. Because-- maybe because I'm moving. I don't know why. That's been a strange thing where, if I'm moving, it's completely fine. I have to move to see it. But if I'm standing still, it's really hard.
呃，我不知道。因为——可能是因为我在移动。我不知道为什么。这是一个奇怪的事，如果我在移动，那就完全没问题。我必须移动才能看到它。但如果我站着不动，这真的很难。
It's funny that you're just running in circles, you know?
你只是在绕圈跑，这挺逗的，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Like, you're not going anywhere.
就像你哪儿也没去一样。
Well, in my head, I am. In my head, I am. I outsmarted you. [GIGGLING]
嗯，在我脑子里，我去过了。在我脑子里，我去过了。我比你聪明。（咯咯笑）
What did you say?
你说什么？
I outsmarted you, Daddy.
我比你聪明，爸爸。
The philosopher, Thomas Nagel, once wrote an essay titled, "What Is It Like to Be a Bat?" Apparently, he had bats in his house, and he wondered if it was possible to truly know what it was like to be a bat, to have webbing on your arms, to perceive the world with sonar, to hang upside down in the attic. His answer was, no, you could not know the mind of such a creature.
哲学家托马斯·内格尔曾写过一篇名为《成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉？》的文章。显然，他家里有蝙蝠，他想知道是否有可能真正了解成为一只蝙蝠是什么感觉，手臂上有蹼是什么感觉，用声呐感知世界是什么感觉，倒挂在阁楼上是什么感觉。他的回答是，不能，你无法知道这种生物的思维。
OK, should we go?
好了，我们要出发吗？
Yeah, go.
去吧。
OK, bye.
好的，再见。
Max did finally agree to let me put a mic on him while he ran around the block. It was like I was right there with him. He was battling some invisible monster.
马克斯终于同意让我把麦克风装在他身上，让他绕街区跑。感觉就像我就在他身边一样。他正在对抗某种隐形的怪物。
[MAX RUNNING]
（马克斯跑步的声音）
I'll be fine.
我会没事的。
"I'll be fine." "I'll be fine," he says.
“我会没事的。”“我会没事的，”他说。
Those cuts are deep.
那些伤口很深。
"Those cuts are deep."
“那些伤口很深。”
It's fine.
没事的。
"It's fine." You're right, Max. It is.
“没事的。”你说得对，马克斯。确实没事。
David Kestenbaum is our show's senior editor.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的资深编辑。
Act Three, "Americans Most Wanted." So we now turn to criminals trying to give the runaround to the police. And in this case, choosing a route that you see now and then in the movies, they escape to Mexico. That's right, across the border to start a new life in a country where they think that they're going to be safe.
第三幕，“美国通缉犯”。我们现在转向那些试图给警察设圈套的罪犯。在这个例子中，他们选择了电影里偶尔会见到的那种路线：逃往墨西哥。没错，穿过边境开始新生活，在一个他们认为自己会安全的地方。
So many people do this. In fact, the numbers are on the rise. The Mexican police formed a special elite unit whose only mandate is to catch these fugitives. The unit's based in Baja California, just south of San Diego. They work with tips they get from the FBI and US Marshals. They are called the Gringo Hunters.
很多人都这么做。事实上，人数还在增加。墨西哥警方成立了一个精英部队，唯一的使命就是抓住这些逃犯。这支部队设在圣迭戈南部的下加利福尼亚州。他们根据从联邦调查局和美国法警那里得到的线索工作。他们被称为“猎杀老美”（Gringo Hunters）。
Kevin Sieff is a reporter for the Washington Post. He hung out with them as they ran around trying to snag fugitives.
凯文·塞夫是《华盛顿邮报》的记者。他和他们一起行动，试图抓获逃犯。
The cops in this special unit find the gringos everywhere-- in beach resorts, at a nightclub, called Papas & Beer, in cars with sex workers, in Carl's Jr parking lots. Some had undergone plastic surgery and acquired new names they couldn't pronounce. Some were found dead.
这支特种部队在任何地方都能找到这些老美——在海滩度假胜地、在一家叫“爸爸和啤酒”（Papas & Beer）的夜店、在有性工作者的车里、在卡乐星停车场的停车场里。有些人做了整容手术，取了连他们自己都念不准的新名字。有些人被发现时已经死了。
They were former Playboy models, amateur surfers, ex-Navy officers. Most of them are alleged serious criminals-- rapists, pedophiles, murderers. The cops have become used to the way American fugitives saunter across the border, expecting that they won't be found.
他们曾经是花花公子模特、业余冲浪者、前海军军官。他们中的大多数是被指控的重罪犯——强奸犯、恋童癖、杀人犯。警察们已经习惯了美国逃犯大摇大摆地穿过边境，觉得他们不会被发现。
Here's Moises. He was the head of the unit when I was there. He's proud of his work, but he gets that it can be kind of funny sometimes.
这是莫伊塞斯。我到那里时他是这个部队的负责人。他为自己的工作感到自豪，但他明白有时这确实挺好笑的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
There's many Americans, I think, that, like in the cartoons and in the movies, that Mexico-- oh, yeah, everybody there has boots and hat and is on a horse or on a donkey. And so then they think, I can go and hide there. And I mean, they-- when they come here to Mexico and they see, no, this is-- here's a city. I mean, it's a big city. And it's even better. I'll hide, and the police will never find me. And when they least expect it, boom, there we are, right in front of them.
我想很多美国人，就像卡通和电影里那样，以为墨西哥——哦，是的，每个人都穿着靴子戴着帽子，骑着马或驴。所以他们认为我可以去那里藏起来。而我的意思是，当他们来到墨西哥看到这里时，不，这里是个城市。我的意思是，是个大城市。而且甚至更好。我会藏起来，警察永远找不到我。当他们最没防备的时候，砰，我们就出现在他们面前。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Moises has been doing the job for 12 years. Hanging out with him, he's like an encyclopedia of gringo fugitives. A lot of the gringos, he tells me, are white guys who think they can make a go of hiding on the coast, blending in with tourists, but they can't.
莫伊塞斯干这一行12年了。和他待在一起，他简直就是“老美逃犯”的百科全书。他告诉我，很多老美是白人男性，认为他们可以在海岸边混下去，混进游客里，但他们做不到。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
The way they dress, the way they walk, the way they express themselves is totally different. The t-shirts are different. If they're wearing shorts, the shorts are different, totally different.
他们的穿着、走路方式、表达自己的方式完全不同。T恤不一样。如果他们穿短裤，短裤也不一样，完全不同。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Even the shoes are totally different. One officer told me the Americans wear flip-flops that are one size too big, usually with socks. Then there are the Mexican-American fugitives who are still such obvious gringos to Moises and the other cops. They're born in the US. They have family in Mexico, but they can never totally blend in either. Something about them is eventually going to betray them as American.
连鞋子都完全不同。一名警官告诉我，美国人穿的凉鞋通常大了一码，而且通常还配着袜子。还有那些墨西哥裔美国人逃犯，对莫伊塞斯和其他警察来说，他们也是如此明显的“老美”。他们在美出生。在墨西哥有家人，但他们也永远无法完全融入。他们身上总有些东西最终会暴露他们是美国人。
That's the kind of fugitive they were chasing when I was with them, a Mexican-American guy named Damion Salinas. He's 20 years old from Fresno, California.
他们和我在一起时追捕的逃犯就是这类人，一个叫达米安·萨利纳斯的墨西哥裔美国小伙。他20岁，来自加州弗雷斯诺。
Back in 2020, Salinas had allegedly murdered another man at the scene of a traffic accident. The killing was shocking, seemingly unprovoked, a gunshot at point-blank range. The victim was a 36-year-old mechanic named Joshua Thao. He was like a father to his nieces and nephews, his sister said. Right before he was shot, witnesses said, he shook the murderer's hand, trying to calm tempers.
回到2020年，萨利纳斯涉嫌在车祸现场谋杀了一名男子。那次杀戮令人震惊，看起来毫无挑衅，在近距离射击。受害者是一名36岁的机械师，名叫约书亚·曹。他姐姐说，他就像他侄子侄女的父亲一样。 witnesses说，在被枪杀前，他握了凶手的手，试图平息愤怒。
After the shooting, Salinas vanished. There were no leads. He'd been a fugitive for almost two years. Now, suddenly, there was new intel. Salinas was supposedly here in Ensenada, about an hour and a half south of the border, cutting hair at a barbershop.
枪击事件后，萨利纳斯失踪了。没有线索。他已经潜逃了近两年。现在，突然有了新情报。萨利纳斯据说就在恩塞纳达，在边境以南一个半小时车程的地方，在一家理发店理发。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Abigail, one of the unit's officers, was leading the planning. They didn't have a search warrant, so they were going to have to find a way to lure Salinas outside.
艾比盖尔是该部队的警官之一，她在带头规划。他们没有搜查令，所以必须想办法引萨利纳斯出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I don't know. Maybe if their car is outside, we can be, like-- maybe, like, find a way to be like, oh, you got a flat tire or something. Could you come out? I think your car has a flat tire. And then when they go out, that's when we get them. We've done that before.
我不知道。也许如果他们的车在外面，我们可以装作——比如，找个理由说，哦，你的车胎瘪了什么的。你能出来看一下吗？我想你的车胎瘪了。当他们出来时，我们就能抓住他们。我们以前干过这个。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Abigail is the only woman on the team. You'd think she's the boss, even though she's not. She's on her phone constantly, pumping her sources and colleagues for more and better intel. That's what she was doing during the Salinas case, shouting a stream of questions into her phone.
艾比盖尔是队里唯一的女性。你会觉得她是头儿，虽然她不是。她不停地打电话，从消息源和同事那里打听更多更好的情报。萨利纳斯案中她就是这么做的，对着电话连珠炮式地发问。
Did Salinas have any connection to Mexico? Who was he living with? Where was he getting his money from? She paused at one point to catch her breath. "Sorry," she said to her colleague. "It's a murder case, so it's a little bit urgent."
萨利纳斯和墨西哥有什么联系吗？他和谁住在一起？他的钱从哪儿来的？她在一处喘了口气。“对不起，”她对同事说，“这是谋杀案，所以有点紧急。”
We get to the barbershop. Abigail and her colleague, Ivan, scope it out from the front seat. Ivan is a former bodyguard. He's the one on the team most likely to show up with a six pack after a big win. He gets a text. There's intel from the US Marshals.
我们到了理发店。艾比盖尔和她的同事伊万在前排观察。伊万曾是保镖。他是团队里最有可能在大功告成后拎着一箱啤酒出现的人。他收到一条短信。那是美国法警发来的情报。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
It was a new tip. They're sending us to another barbershop, Ivan says.
那是条新情报。他们把我们派往另一家理发店，伊万说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
It sounds like Salinas is in Tijuana, about an hour north. So Abigail floors it along the highway that traces the Pacific Ocean, driving close to 100 miles an hour.
听起来萨利纳斯在提华纳，往北约一小时车程。于是艾比盖尔沿着太平洋沿岸的公路猛踩油门，时速接近100英里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Signs of the gringo presence are everywhere, big billboards in English that say things like "Invest In Your New Ocean View House." Another said "Thong and Tequila Party." In some ways, this part of Mexico seems perfect for Americans trying to disappear. But Abigail has become a pro at drawing them out.
到处都是老美存在的迹象，巨大的英文广告牌写着“投资你的新海景房”。另一个写着“丁字裤和龙舌兰派对”。在某些方面，墨西哥的这个区域对于试图消失的美国人来说似乎非常完美。但艾比盖尔已经成了诱捕他们的高手。
She told me earlier that morning about one of her new strategies. She's created a bunch of fake Facebook accounts using stock photos of attractive women that she uses to catfish fugitives. One guy had actually posted on a Facebook group looking to meet people. He even used his real name.
她那天早上早些时候告诉了我她的一种新策略。她用迷人的女性照片创建了一堆虚假的Facebook账号，用来钓鱼逃犯。有一个家伙甚至在一个Facebook群组里发帖寻找结识对象。他甚至用了真名。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He wanted to smoke some weed, and he wanted to smoke it with me, and stay overnight at my place, and have a crazy night. And I said, yes.
他想抽点大麻，想和我一起抽，想在我家过夜，想有一个疯狂的夜晚。我说，好啊。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
So yeah, he brought his little suitcase with his clothes, and he thought he was going to stay with me for a few days, all, like, washed up and cologned.
所以他带着装衣服的小行李箱来了，他以为要在那里陪我几天，洗得干干净净，喷了古龙水。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Another cop from the unit cuts in and starts to troll Abigail. "Sometimes they arrive stinky," he says. "It's so you don't have to struggle with the stinky perp, right?" he says. "You just want to deliver them nice and clean, no fuss, back to the gringos."
该部队的另一名警察插话，开始调侃艾比盖尔。“有时他们到的时候很臭，”他说。“这样你就不用和臭烘烘的罪犯纠缠了，对吧？”他说。“你只想把他们洗得干干净净，不麻烦地送回去，交给那些老美。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Abigail grew up in Tijuana, secretly dreaming of becoming a police officer. Her mother begged her not to. Being a cop was dangerous. But she says she was born to do the job. Abigail waited until her own daughter was a little over two, and then she signed up.
艾比盖尔在提华纳长大，偷偷梦想着成为一名警察。她妈妈求她不要这样。当警察太危险了。但她说她是为这份工作而生的。艾比盖尔等到自己的女儿两岁多一点时，就报名参警了。
The stakes feel so high to her. The gringos coming across, they could just repeat their crimes on her side of the border. She told me about the case of a pedophile who fled the US. He moved into a house near a Tijuana elementary school where he was getting ready to look for more kids to abuse. She was like, if we don't catch this guy today, who knows what he'll do here in Mexico?
赌注对她来说太大了。那些过来的老美可能会在边境线这边重复他们的罪行。她告诉了我一个恋童癖从美国潜逃的案件。他搬进了一所靠近提华纳小学附近的房子，准备在那里寻找更多的孩子进行虐待。她说，如果我们今天不抓住这家伙，谁知道他在墨西哥会干出什么事？
When we arrived in Tijuana, we parked across from the second barbershop and Ivan and Abigail began their surveillance. As always, they work undercover. Today, jeans and t-shirts, like two friends headed out for a day at the beach.
当我们到达提华纳时，我们停在了第二家理发店对面，伊万和艾比盖尔开始监视。像往常一样，他们卧底工作。今天穿的是牛仔裤和T恤，就像两个要去海滩度过一天的一样。
Abigail bought some nachos from the shop next door, slyly peering into the barber shop. Ivan put on a black backpack and walked by-- disguised, I guess, as a 30-something-year-old student. Then we all settled in the car and got comfortable staring through the windshield.
艾比盖尔从隔壁店买了些玉米片，偷偷地往理发店里瞧。伊万背着一个黑色背包走过——伪装成一个30多岁的学生。然后我们都坐进车里，透过挡风玻璃盯着看，很自在。
Usually on stakeouts, Ivan is constantly turning up the volume on Bad Bunny. Today, he's kind of bragging, showing me dozens of photos of the gringos he's arrested, like a yearbook of American fugitives. Then they get another call.
通常在盯梢时，伊万会不停地调大Bad Bunny的音乐。今天他在吹牛，向我展示他逮捕的几十张老美照片，就像美国逃犯的年鉴。然后他们又接到一个电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Someone has left the apartment above the barbershop. The person got into a gold Honda Accord and drove away. One of the agents says over the radio, "I think it's Salinas." Then they take off, cutting across four lanes of traffic. Abigail cuts off the Honda and they surround the car.
有人离开了理发店上面的公寓。那个人上了辆金色的本田雅阁开走了。其中一名探员在电台里说：“我想是萨利纳斯。”然后他们冲了出去，横跨四条车道。艾比盖尔截停了本田车，他们包围了车辆。
I'm watching them approach the car and this is kind of a scary moment. Only a few weeks before, the cops had been in a shootout with a fugitive from California. Moises and Ivan got shot. The team told me that they were worried that Salinas too might come out shooting if he was cornered.
我看着他们接近那辆车，这是一个相当恐怖的时刻。就在几周前，警察还和一名加州的逃犯发生过枪战。莫伊塞斯和伊万中弹了。队里告诉我，他们担心如果萨利纳斯被困住，可能会开枪反击。
I watch them pull a skinny guy out of the driver's seat and push him against the car. He didn't look to me like the guy I'd seen in the Most Wanted posters. Then they take his wallet from his back pocket. There's a California driver's license with the name Damion Salinas. They get out their handcuffs.
我看着他们把一个瘦骨嶙峋的家伙从驾驶座拉出来，把他按在车上。在我看来他不像我在“通缉令”海报上看到的那个家伙。然后他们从他后兜里拿出了钱包。里面有一张加州驾照，名字是达米安·萨利纳斯。他们拿出了手铐。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
Damion.
达米安。
Damion, OK. Do you have other ID? Only have this?
达米安，好的。你有其他证件吗？只有这个？
Only that, so. It's valid.
只有那个，所以。是有效的。
You have something you might-- in the car?
车里有什么吗？
No.
没有。
Nothing. Gun?
没有什么。有枪吗？
You have guns?
你有枪吗？
No.
没有。
Drugs?
有毒品吗？
No. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
没有。（西班牙语）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Even after all the build up, there was still something startling about seeing the cops catch their fugitive. It was surreal. They start figuring out logistics. Who's going to take the gold Honda? Salinas seems confused. He starts saying, "I will go--" And that's when Abigail interrupts him. "No, you're coming with us."
即使在做了所有铺垫之后，看着警察抓捕逃犯依然令人震惊。这太超现实了。他们开始商量后勤问题。谁来开那辆金色的本田？萨利纳斯似乎很困惑。他开始说：“我会去——”就在这时艾比盖尔打断了他。“不，你跟我们走。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Salinas doesn't put up a fight. They stick him in the backseat of the car, and I ask if I can sit next to him to ask a few questions. They say sure, but they put the biggest cop in the unit between us, in case Salinas lunges at me. But he doesn't. He looks like he'd just woken up from a nap.
萨利纳斯没有反抗。他们把他塞进后座，我问能不能坐在他旁边问几个问题。他们说可以，但把队里最高大的警察安排在我们中间，以防萨利纳斯扑向我。但他没有。他看起来像是刚从午睡中醒来。
Yeah, I'm not a-- just to be clear, I'm not a law enforcement official. I'm-- I'm a journalist.
是的，我不是——要说明一下，我不是执法人员。我是——我是个记者。
Wait, you're--
等等，你是——
Sorry?
对不起？
What are you again?
你到底是干什么的？
I'm a journalist.
我是个记者。
Journalist?
记者？
Yeah.
是的。
Those are badass jobs. I like them.
那可是个很酷的工作。我喜欢。
It's interesting, sometimes.
有时确实很有趣。
This whole day, I'd been wondering, what is this guy going to be like? How had he evaded authorities for almost two years? I think I'd been expecting an angry, sophisticated criminal. This guy, after all, was being accused of homicide.
这一整天，我都在想，这家伙会是什么样？他是如何逃避当局近两年的？我想我当时期待的是一个愤怒、老练的罪犯。毕竟，这家伙被指控谋杀。
But Salinas is like a kid trying to disguise himself as a man. His mustache is wispy. He's wearing Air Jordan sandals with socks. "Forever West Coast" was tattooed on his right arm.
但萨利纳斯就像个试图伪装成大人的孩子。他的胡子稀稀拉拉。他穿着穿着袜子的Air Jordan凉鞋。他的右臂纹着“永远西海岸”。
I'm a good dude, man.
我可是个好人，伙计。
He keeps saying how nervous he is, but then he spins a tale about how he'd only been caught because he let his guard down.
他一直说他有多紧张，但随后他又编了个故事，说他被抓完全是因为放松了警惕。
Why didn't you try to go further into Mexico? Like, you stayed so close to the border.
你为什么不试着往墨西哥更深处走呢？你待得离边境太近了。
Well, I mean, I'm not a dumbass though. I know why they caught me. I just stopped trying after a while, you know? Things got-- you know? The cops are not really that smart, you know? So every place they hit, I was right-- I was always watching them. I watched them like they watched me. And after a while, I just gave up. I was like, fuck it.
好吧，我的意思是，我也不是个傻瓜。我知道他们为什么抓到我。只是后来我不打算再试了，你知道吗？事情变得——你知道吗？警察其实没那么聪明，你知道吗？所以他们去的每个地方，我都在——我一直在观察他们。我观察他们就像他们观察我一样。过了一段时间，我就放弃了。我当时想，去他的。
Why'd you give up?
你为什么要放弃？
I was just going through a lot, you know, being alone and shit, the depression.
我经历了太多事，你知道吗，那种孤独和狗屎一样的抑郁感。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, PTSD kicks in, all kinds of shit, so.
你知道，创伤后应激障碍发作了，所有那些鬼东西，所以。
So you basically were like-- resigned yourself to getting caught. Almost wanted to get caught, it sounds like.
所以你基本上是——认命了，准备被抓。听起来几乎是你自己想被抓。
Yeah, basically. Sometimes, I get--
是的，基本上。有时，我会被——
Abigail weaves through Tijuana traffic with the siren on. We're headed to the border to hand Salinas over to US authorities. And then Ivan puts on "Gangsta's Paradise" and turns up the volume. He tells me, "Ask him if he's a rapper."
艾比盖尔开着警笛在提华纳的车流中穿行。我们正前往边境把萨利纳斯交给美国当局。然后伊万放起了“黑帮天堂”，把音量调大。他告诉我：“问问他是不是个说唱歌手。”
Are you a rapper? Or were you ever a rapper?
你是说唱歌手吗？还是你曾经是？
Yeah, I like rap.
是的，我喜欢说唱。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
You have a song?
你有歌吗？
Have you ever sung a song?
你唱过歌吗？
Nah, no. I never.
没有，从没有。
And then they pull up a video on Ivan's cell phone. It's a video of Salinas rapping, taken from his social media.
然后他们调出了伊万手机里的一个视频。那是萨利纳斯说唱的视频，从他的社交媒体上抓取的。
[SALINAS RAPPING]
（萨利纳斯说唱的声音）
Oh, yeah. That's me.
哦，是的。那就是我。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Why-- why did you lie and say you didn't have a song if you had a song?
为什么——为什么你刚才要撒谎说你没歌，如果你明明有歌？
I'm not getting embarrassed, man. That's why.
我不想丢脸，伙计。就是这样。
Salinas seems calm at this point. Abigail parks the car at the border and the Mexican police march Salinas past a long line of people, the daily border crossers and migrants who are waiting to enter the US on foot. They crane their necks to look at the American fugitive. A small group of uniformed US officials is standing at the border. One of the agents bends his knees in a blocker's position, as if Salinas might make a run for it.
萨利纳斯此时看起来很平静。艾比盖尔把车停在边境，墨西哥警察押着萨利纳斯走过长长的一排人，那些是每天在边境步行进入美国的跨境人员和移民。他们伸长脖子看着这个美国逃犯。一群穿制服的美国官员站在边境线上。其中一名探员弯着膝盖做防守姿势，好像萨利纳斯会逃跑似的。
Yeah, we know. We know all about it, so. We got-- we got the phone calls. You guys want to bring him? Come on in. All right, thanks, man. He's coming with us.
是的，我们知道。我们全知道，所以。我们接到了电话。你们要把他带过来？进来吧。好的，谢谢伙计。他跟我们走。
The Mexican police take off the Mexican handcuffs and the Americans put on American cuffs. It feels almost ceremonial. The arrest is done, the gringo is back in gringo hands.
墨西哥警察摘下墨西哥手铐，美国人戴上美国手铐。感觉几乎是仪式性的。逮捕完成了，老美回到了老美手里。
I watched the Gringo Hunters walk back from the border to their car. They had just arrested an alleged murderer. I look for some kind of reaction. I'm not sure what, exactly-- a high five, a look of accomplishment, but there was almost nothing. The unit chases and catches so many gringos that Salinas was just another name on their list. They already had their next day's assignment-- a woman had kidnapped and drugged a child. They too were likely living in Tijuana.
我看着“猎杀老美”小组走回他们的车边。他们刚刚逮捕了一名涉嫌谋杀的人。我寻找着某种反应。我不知道确切是什么——击掌，成就感，但几乎什么都没有。这支小组追捕并逮捕了太多的老美，萨利纳斯不过是他们名单上的另一个名字。他们已经有了第二天的工作任务——一名女子绑架并给一名儿童下了药。他们很可能也住在提华纳。
A few weeks after the Salinas chase, I was talking to Moises, the head of the Gringo Hunters, and he told me this thing. He said that sometimes he's hanging out with his friends who are not cops, and he gets this feeling that I think cops everywhere get, that regular people just don't know how many bad guys are out there. They don't know how scary it can feel to chase fugitive Americans day in and day out.
在萨利纳斯追捕行动几周后，我和“猎杀老美”小组的头儿莫伊塞斯交谈时，他告诉我一件事。他说有时他和非警察的朋友在一起，他会有种警察到处都会有的感觉，就是普通人根本不知道外面有多少坏人。他们不知道每天追捕逃犯的美国人会有多可怕。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
What I do is so that, right now, you guys can all be hanging out here comfortably. Because if we didn't do it, we'd be surrounded by all these kind of people. Like, we wouldn't be able to just hang out in the afternoons and the evenings, because we'd just be looking over our shoulder.
我做这些是为了让你们现在能舒服地待在这儿。因为如果我们不做，我们会被这种人包围。我们甚至无法在下午或晚上出来玩，因为我们得一直盯着背后。
Because we've caught an infinite number of Americans, eh? I've participated in, I don't know, around 1,300, 1,200 fugitive arrests. I mean, that's a lot of fugitives we've arrested. That's two or three per week, 140, 150 a year, per year.
因为我们抓住了无数的美国人，嘿？我参与了，我不知道，大约1300，1200起逃犯逮捕。我的意思是，我们逮捕了太多的逃犯。那是一周两三次，一年140、150起，每年。
And it never ends, right? They just keep on coming.
而且没完没了，对吧？他们一个接一个地来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Yeah. Yeah, they just keep on coming. They keep on coming. And I mean, there are times when things slow down, but then suddenly it's like-- like they all agree to come across at the same time. I don't know. I like to say that they all came on the same bus or something.
是的。是的，他们一直来。他们一直来。而且我的意思是，有时节奏会慢下来，但突然间就——就像他们约好了一起穿过边境。我不知道。我喜欢说他们都是坐同一辆巴士来的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Moises doesn't come out and say it, but chasing American fugitives all day, it has shaped how he sees the United States. Part of the problem, he says, is that in the US, it's so easy to get a gun. On some of his trips there, it seemed like everyone was armed.
莫伊塞斯没有明说，但整天追捕美国逃犯，已经塑造了他对美国的看法。他说，问题的一部分在于在美国，弄到枪太容易了。在他的一些旅行中，看起来每个人都有武装。
As we talked, it struck me that he'd come to see Mexico as being in a perilous position, bordering this heavily-armed, crime-infested nation. I had heard that tone before. He spoke with a very real fear and perhaps a little bit of hysteria, the same way I've heard so many Americans talk about a lawless Mexico.
当我们交谈时，我突然意识到他已经把墨西哥视为一个处于危险境地的国家，邻接着这样一个全副武装、犯罪泛滥的国家。我以前听过那种论调。他说时带有非常真实的恐惧，或许还有一点歇斯底里，就像我听到太多美国人谈论无法无天的墨西哥一样。
Kevin Sieff of the Washington Post. He also did a print version of this story with pictures that you can find online at the Post website. The story was produced by Nadia Reiman.
《华盛顿邮报》的凯文·塞夫。他还制作了这个故事的纸质版和图片，可以在邮报网站上在线查阅。该报道由纳迪亚·雷曼制作。
["RUN-AROUND" BY BLUES TRAVELER]
（布鲁斯旅行者乐队的《跑断腿》）
Well, our program was produced today by Chris Benderev. The people who put our show together today includes Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由克里斯·本德列夫制作。今天参与制作节目的还有埃尔娜·贝克、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、安德烈亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、伯特利·哈布特、卡西·豪利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿莉莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
The voice actors in the Gringo Hunter story were Luis Bordonada and Chelsea Rendon. Special thanks today to Deborah Harris, Kimi Yoshino, Susan Davis, Patrick Creamer, Matt Bonaccorsi, Caitlyn Hodgkins, Nate Cross, Benjamin Kowalski, Nina Reinhardt, Kim McBride, Marc Butakis, Luke Vander Ploeg, Sabrina Hyman, and Fernando Monroy. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos There's also lists of favorite shows to listen to, tons of other stuff-- thisamericanlife.org.
“猎杀老美”故事的配音演员是路易斯·博尔多纳达和切尔西·兰登。特别感谢黛博拉·哈里斯、基米·吉野、苏珊·戴维斯、帕特里克·克里默、马特·博纳科西、凯特琳·霍奇金斯、内特·克罗斯、本杰明·科瓦尔斯基、尼娜·莱因哈特、金·麦克布莱德、马克·布塔基斯、卢克·范德普洛格、萨布丽娜·海曼和费尔南多·蒙罗伊。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费流媒体收听超过750期的往期节目。还有视频、最喜爱剧集的列表等等——thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he tried to give me his recipe for turducken. I don't know. I just don't think he got it right.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台PRX提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他尝试把turducken（填馅鸡鸭火鸡）的食谱给我。我不知道。我觉得他没弄对。
It's pretty much just a little chicken, a little duck, and they were literally friends.
基本就是讲一只小鸡、一只小鸭，它们真的是朋友。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
["RUN-AROUND" BY BLUES TRAVELER]
（布鲁斯旅行者乐队的《跑断腿》）